oh hi there see you here to answer your
questions with my sidekick Kieran that
hello it run so it maybe we'll get right
into it yeah okay so we have really a
lot of good questions
okay first one is do you recommend
focusing on communicating instead of
perfection absolutely perfection is
unachievable there is no language that I
speak to perfection okay even including
English and the whole thing is
communicating because it makes it real
you have a real purpose and for learning
the language you want to communicate
with other people you make a mistake as
long as your message is coming across
and you understand what they're saying
that's what it's all about it's not
about perfection excellent all right so
the next one is if my native language is
Spanish do you think French would be an
easy language to learn yes because well
it's not easy but it's easier because
the bigger fact the biggest factor is
vocabulary in my experience the more
similar the vocabulary the easier it is
to learn the language so French and
Spanish I don't know what the number is
85% of the vocabulary is is recognizable
I mean it's written different it's
somewhat different but it's more or less
there however you can't assume that
because was he saying he spoke French or
Spanish uh they actually speak Spanish
shake that
well you had as soon it's going to be
easy because in fact each of these even
like Portuguese and Spanish there are
parts of the grammar that are different
and words that mean slightly different
things so you can't assume that you're
going to ace it but you have such a big
advantage because 80% of the vocabulary
you'll recognize so it's never easy but
it's easier okay all right I'm moving to
the next one in Mandarin do you suggest
learning traditional Chinese characters
or simplified characters it depends on
your needs and interests when I learned
Chinese we began with the traditional
characters and then we move to the
simplified and so I have the advantage
that if I'm in Hong Kong or Taiwan I can
read the newspaper I think nowadays
practically most people are dealing with
mainland
China but the People's Republic so
probably simplified is enough if you
have the interest I would start with the
traditional spend a bit of time there
and move to the simplified however if
you you're in a hurry you want to get on
you want to read just just study the
simplified it really doesn't matter I
think it's like so much in language
learning is up to you what are your
interests
okay I think either way is a good way to
go but if you learn the traditional it's
very easy learns okay okay um what was
the biggest challenge you had to
overcome in language learning well I
think the biggest challenge always is
because to me language learning is about
getting something that is not in you
like the new language to get it into you
okay so it doesn't come from inside it
comes from outside right so the
challenge is always to find meaningful
interesting content and so when I went
to study German back whenever it was
1986-87 I scour this is before link
existed I scoured the secondhand
bookstores in Vancouver to find readers
because I don't want to look every word
up in the dictionary yeah so you know
readers that have glossaries and so if
you can if you can find interesting
content and more recently learning you
know polish as I mentioned you know
finding interesting content there it's
all about finding interesting content
okay it used to be that you had to find
content that had like a word list
because looking stuff up in a dictionary
is very time-consuming and very
frustrating because you forget
immediately after closing the dictionary
but so but nowadays with programs like
Lync online dictionaries and stuff like
that the key is to find interesting
meaningful content that's the biggest
obstacle I feel alright okay so what do
you think about the FSI language series
and colloquial I think and yes yeah well
Curl Curl is a bit like teach yourself
these are the sort of starter books
right now where they say on the cover if
you complete this you will you know
master reading writing listening which
of course isn't true
they're basically entered
dr. ebooks to the language okay
colloquial I think has gotten worse as
has teach yourself because they put more
and more English on their audio all I
want from them is some audio some words
some explanations of grammar which I'm
going to forget but it kind of
introduces me to the language I see I
find now I
I need those kinds of booklet books less
and less if I still buy them because
they're handy to have so colloquial
teach yourself those and introductory
books you buy them you go back to time
and time again right in your learning
FSI is different FSI is sort of like a
system based on sort of very repetitive
drills this is a car this is a blue car
this is my blue car I find those deadly
boring I got some with all due respect
to FSI I got some car a couple of
language I just couldn't stay with it it
gets back to this idea and this is
applicable to colloquial as well
meaningful interesting content so
important so you can do a little bit of
FSI but I can do it okay I can do it so
yeah again I think that it could be part
of your language learning program but to
me the biggest part of my time you spent
again listening and reading to
meaningful content nice using native I
think this next point actually kind of
ties in do you use a monolingual
dictionary on this one user says I think
you want to start using that from low to
intermediate and it helps them to become
fluent faster and the target language is
that that true I only use a month in
other words I will always use a
bilingual dictionary okay until I am so
good in the language that it's almost
like my native language in which case I
don't care but but most of the time
you're looking for a quick and again in
the link we use a term hint because when
you see them the meaning a meaning in
the dictionary that's not the complete
range of meaning of that word that gets
you started so you see the word in this
context in that context I don't want to
read and I have used
on lingual dictionaries and I end up
with a bunch more words that I don't
know so here's a word I don't know I
look up and in the lang I'm running poll
they should look up a polish definition
of that word and there's more words that
I don't know to me but a lot of people
claim that using a monolingual
dictionary is good I have never found
that to be the case and I don't use them
I violate well it can be bilingual to
French or the language that I speak very
well but if I'm learning polish I won't
use a Polish dictionary okay you said in
the past that French is one of your
strongest languages so with that do you
ever keep learning new French words and
vocabulary with authentic sources such
as yoga mode or whatever one no order no
I mean my French is at the point where
you know it's good enough right and but
just by reading I do a lot of reading in
French and I will just like any native
speaker you continue to accumulate words
you see them a different context might
be curious and you might look it up but
I don't do any deliberate learning a
French but I do listen and read French
okay listen to and read French yes all
right another here another question here
from the user says I've been living in
Australia since 2013 when I moved here I
had just basic English now I'm
intermediate I would like to achieve an
advanced level but still know very few
words what's your advice well this gets
back to the idea that to my mind to be
good in the language you need a lot of
words a lot of people say you know I can
be tremendously fluent with a few other
words if this person here I don't know
if it's a he or a she if they're living
and working in Australia and they're
surrounded by English native English
speakers who have a large vocabulary
depending on their level of education
forty fifty sixty thousand words you're
going to be communicating with those
people you need a large achill category
so yeah you've got to do a lot of
reading I mean it all comes back to
reading and listening get on link build
up your vocabulary when I yes when I
study Russian polish Czech I want to
drive that gnome
where's number up to you know as I've
said my goal in Polish so they want to
get over to over 30,000 words in Polish
it's just you got to have that
vocabulary and if you acquire the
vocabulary through risk listening and
reading
you know your brain is also getting used
to the language right so you've got to
read you got to read novels in the
language is meet immigrants here and
they say you know we I can read fine but
I can't speak and I only refine I say do
you have your read a novel No so get to
where you can read a novel and you can
enjoy reading a novel of the language
all right okay well that was it for Oh
getting we did it Yeah right keep your
questions coming and and keep up the
good work and the challenge see you guys
next week